never really quite knew how to play a
vampire though
for a series as beloved as twilight was
when it came out it still isn't hard to
see why the actors would be embarrassed
to film it grown adults catering to the
fantasies of 13 year old girls is super
weird ready to check it out spider
monkey not blushing more than a little
bit number one men are sensitive about
their bodies too taylor lautner was in
the best shape of his life during the
filming of twilight but that doesn't
mean he was a huge fan of flaunting what
he had on set all the time if he had his
way he would have preferred to keep his
shirt on
jacob
put your clothes on
one moment he remembers feeling quite
insecure was when he was leaning against
the car with his arms behind his head he
recalls being the only shirtless guy
those scenes are the worst while lautner
found it uncomfortable he wouldn't be
opposed to doing more movies shirtless
if the role required it number two you
could have just tore a strip off your
shirt like they do in the action movies
another lotner cringefest moment was
when jacob noticed that bella was
bleeding he immediately tore off his
shirt and offered it to bella for her
wound this one is especially cringy so
much so that every time lautner watches
it afterwards he can't help but laugh in
embarrassment number three lower your
expectations for a first time who can
forget that bed breaking scene in
breaking dawn part one wait realization
here was breaking dawn a metaphor for
losing your virginity kristen stewart
had the giggles while filming her
intimate scene with robert pattinson
there was way too much pressure on her
for the love-making fest to be
transcendent inhuman and otherworldly
and she was like how do you live up to
that the feeling of inadequacy that came
with it was just not helpful and to make
matters worse they had to do reshoots on
the scene because it was initially given
an r rating which would have kept at
least half of the fan base out of the
movie theater and streaming it illegally
i haven't seen it
really
number four the second time in bed is
just as awkward the couple is tucked
away incredibly far from humanity and to
the rest of the cullens because vampires
get so wild in the bedroom they need to
be isolated from the rest of humanity
and vampire kind alike
i always prefer
pretending to have sex when you're
getting paid
robert pattinson admitted to being
incredibly embarrassed having to film
the scene in front of a whole crew of
people making the fake o sound and all
they're all
pointing and laughing but the worst part
was to keep the rating pg-13 there was
no thrusting allowed and it was
incredibly daunting for robert pattinson
because it's a pg-13 intimate scene
where it's supposed to seem like the
love-making is out of this world in
retrospect that is super weird the worst
was when he was like we wanted to be
really inside of the experience and so
for your close-up you're not gonna be
looking at rob you're gonna be actually
just looking directly into the lens
you see yourself when you look directly
into the lens you can just see yourself
number five yay we did it or you did it
i'm just here for the craft table anna
was kind of embarrassed because she was
hardly in the movies and then in number
four she got to just appear and
celebrate with the rest of the cast as
if she'd been pouring her blood sweat
and tears into it like the rest of them
cheering guys we did it it's over number
six seriously go google this after the
babies are heckin adorable but more than
likely photoshopped robert pattinson has
made no secret of his feelings for
working on twilight he's opened up about
the most ridiculous of moments like the
one where they discovered bella was
pregnant with a hybrid vampire baby the
response from the cullen family was to
immediately search one page on google
vampire baby like
he found it to be the most ridiculous
scene to film because they're all 300
year old geniuses he makes a good point
number seven we want to know what
product he's using robert pattinson
found the most uncomfortable of things
to be the descriptions in the script
every paragraph there's like a thing he
said edward's introduction was just
insane he stopped reading it when it
said his hair was dripping wet
disheveled even so he looked like he
just finished shooting a commercial for
hair gel our pats just found it pretty
unbelievable
i was like oh jesus there's no
there's no way number eight sorry
stephanie meyer rob said it not us
robert pattinson had no idea why girls
liked the story but what he found weird
was that when he read it i was convinced
that stephanie was
convinced she was bella and he was just
reading her fantasy he was totally
convinced that she was in love with her
own fictional creation and it made him
uncomfortable it was like it was a book
that wasn't supposed to be published
number nine yeah this is weird demon
baby jacob falls in love with the little
baby
you can just tell from the little giggle
fit between our pats in case two that
jacob falling in love with the little
demon baby embarrassed the heck out of
everyone fell in love with the baby
number 10 the wolf boy admits defeat
with his tail tucked between his legs
taylor lautner's character saying to
edward and bella you guys
really look great together felt very
strange to the actor say to them
you two looked great together it was
just
strange number 11 you can't really
expect two strangers to be excited about
a kissing scene she would get so excited
about stuff like that the intimacy test
between rob and kristen was super odd
because there was no lines in the whole
thing and director catherine hardwick
would get super excited like so you guys
ready number 12 don't tempt me i will
eat you the description in the scene
where rob has to look at the guys who
are hassling bella goes he gives a a
look so
devilish so animalistic
it's fury that terrifies four grown men
coming out dressed in his bouffant
hairdo with his white makeup and peacoat
made it quite difficult very scary
number 13. the vehicles were real
beaters just like they looked in the
movies apparently there was something
wrong with the vehicle doors in twilight
it happened at least twice where k-stew
and lautner tried to open the doors and
they just wouldn't open number 14. that
feel when you put your damsel in more
distress running with a full-grown woman
in your arms is not easy especially when
you're running through the forest this
is one thing rob and taylor could agree
on as they both tripped and fell while
carrying kristen stewart
there were some moments during that that
we couldn't keep straight faces number
15 cpr is always awkward this just took
it to a whole new level lautner found
the moment he had to do cpr on bella in
the fourth movie super awkward they just
could not keep straight faces no matter
how much they tried number 16 good luck
intimidating a guy twice your size
robb's character attempts to intimidate
jacob at one point
it didn't go that way during filming
though rob grabbed lautner's wrist and
was embarrassed it was so freaking thick
there's no way to intimidate that buff
boy number 17 when you feel like a wolf
on the inside but look like a gray
squirrel on the outside before cgi did
its magic on the wolf jacob was there in
a little gray suit and you can trust
that robert pattinson was there to make
fun of the guy the whole time he's not
the hero we wanted but he's the one we
needed i think if anything else happens
to bella and edward at this point i'm
just gonna be like i don't care just
kill him i think at this point they
deserve their happiness it's like just
leave them alone
who knew twilight was so cringe behind
the scenes everyone we owe taylor
lautner an apology for oggling his body
just a little too much while the days of
team edward or team jacob seemed to be
behind us our you team loved the
franchise or hated it let us know in the
comments and thanks for watching